let me tell you about my mother in law
this woman has no chill about her
she is always on the go
always doing something and is always down for an adventure
and I think quite honestly
she is my kids and his excuse to have adventures
and so today is my son's sixth birthday
it also happens to be the grand opening of the Great Wolfage in Naples
which is where we live and so instead of just having a normal sleepover tonight
like they do on any given day of the week
she decides it's best to book a suite at the Great Wolf Lodge
to celebrate his sixth birthday
yeah so instead of just having a casual movie night at home
they're gonna go party and swim at the indoor water park
it's fine it's fine
and I could be upset
because she's taking them to do an experience that I don't get to be a part of
but instead I think about the memories that my kids get to make with them
and that they get to do something fun
and it's going to be a birthday that he's always gonna remember
and that is what it matters